who's the the best actor that you loved
working with the most
that's a terrible question the actor you
loved working with the most in the
history of your life
so far tara another terrible framing of
a question
um i've i've
thought that's hard i mean yeah i mean
obviously
like it feels ridiculous to sort of say
anyone else really
um you know there's people who i feel
that i've
i've had closer relationships with and
people who
have probably probably taught me more um
but just the level of of just how good
he was
and how fortunate and ridiculous
it was for me to have been working with
him at that age
um it seems a bit stupid to even
suggest anyone else i mean he was it's
just
i i watch his performances now and i'm
just like still going just
like i wish i could have that time
again
i wish i could go back and and do and
and work with him again and and from
from like what i know now from
everything that i've
appreciate of him now but i've been as a
stupid kid you know kids are stupid
well you were 17 at the end when you had
scenes with him right
now i would have been 20 20 years old
you were 20 years old so you were an
adult
yeah yeah i just um i was i was very
uh i wasn't the outgoing charming man
that you speak to
now i was very very shy back then and
um i didn't uh
i didn't i guess take advantage of the
wrong word but i just didn't
uh i didn't speak to hardly any of them
to be honest with you
um we you know it i just
was terrified of of them for no reason
whatsoever because they're all so
all of them were so nice and so friendly
and you know
people i've spoken to years later like
michael gambon and robbie coltrane and a
few of the guys that i've sort of
since become friends with years later i
wish i could have had that relationship
when i was younger i just
didn't and obviously sadly allen's one
that i never got a chance to meet again
after we
after the final premieres and stuff and
i just wish that
i wish i mean i guess we all have these
regrets of when we're younger we look
back and we go oh you idiot why did
you do that oh why didn't you do that
um but i do i would that's what i do
wish i could go back and
and work with him again knowing what i
know now
yeah that's pretty profound and it is
it's sad it's like you know but that's
like
you take it as this was a great moment i
got to watch him work i got to work with
him
and you take take it for you know take
it for what it's worth and what you did
even like telling them like i guess
must hear it all the time like people
like that must must genuinely hear it
all the time oh my god i'm your biggest
fan oh i think you're amazing
but you know as a young actor like these
are people who
have shaped you in ways you didn't even
realize just from a film you watched
when you were nine like you know what i
mean like they
they have they have had an impact on
your career without you even realizing
it some of them
and i don't feel i mean i said i did i
did tell alan
that actually on on the last day i did i
did say something
along those lines um would you say so
many of them i
i didn't well i i i i think i
must have told you this i um on on his
last day i went to his trailer and
even knocking on his door
terrifying um
and uh and i just said to him
hey um i know it's your last day and i
just wanted to say
this has been incredible like to have
worked with you
for this long i know that we've not
really spoken very much
um but i just want to say that it wasn't
you know it was because i was terrified
but you were incredible and
i just want to say thank you for
allowing me to work with you for
10 years and not ever shouting at me or
you know treating any of us anything
less than you're equal
um and he was like come on in and
when he put the kettle on and we had a
cup of tea and we just chatted about
what i was going to do you know in my
career going forward and
what he recommended i do and and uh
yeah i mean it was just i'm so glad i
did that i wish i'd done it
five years earlier you know i mean um
but i was
at least i can say i did that like
that's one thing like i never did that
with anyone else i didn't know that
story
oh yeah yeah so because he was i think
he was um
i don't know what his job title was but
he was he was he was
quite important at radha at the time i'm
not entirely sure exactly what he was
like he was
president or something of radar i don't
know um and he was talking about how he
thought i should go to drama school
um that was probably him
very politely criticizing me um i'm
kidding i'm kidding but this is what
goes through my head all the time right
um but he was no he did say you can do
it he said that to me those are his
words
you know you you can do it um
but his point was that i would need um
my skills would need honing and he was
absolutely right about that
and he recommended theater and doing
theater and that's why i did some
theater
which i mean he couldn't have been more
right about that that
i learned so much more so much more
about myself
as not only just an actor but as a
person
like what what do i want out of life
what do i want out of this career i
learned all that on stage i didn't learn
that on harry potter
i learned all that like when you're in
the
firing line of of critics every week on
stage
um and uh i developed all my
thick skin and and and well thicker skin
um doing that and that's what i think he
was
telling me to go and do you know going
because
how if you're doing harry potter you've
got it easy you're uh
you can hide behind a lot of people you
can hide behind scenery for crying out
loud you can get away with
a lot when you're doing 40 takes of
every scene
and and you've got
spells going off and explosions and all
this it's they can just chop and chop
that to pieces they're gonna make
everyone look
respectable you know so yeah